so we've been talking quite a bit about
the Catholic Church considering some I
guess what we would call progressive or
at least leftward reforms within its
organization and I thought for today's
classic interview we'd go back to a very
odd interview I did back in 2014 with a
guy named James White sort of quirky
anti-gay pastor and I thought we could
all sort of reflect on how much society
would benefit from reforming some of the
wackiness out of established religion so
let's get right to it
I'm joined today by James White he is a
current you CC pastor and he is located
in the gold tree Oklahoma Church so
let's start first James what is the UCC
what denomination is that the United
Church of Christ is a combination of the
merger took place in the early 60s
between the evangelical and reformed
church a Congregational Christian Church
they're very liberal and our partners so
to speak with disciples of Christ if
you're ordained to one you can be a
minister in the other and vice versa it
seems here lately a lot of the church
growth has come because of MCC churches
that left the Metropolitan Community
Church and joined the UCC okay so what
what's that that tells us what it is but
I don't I want to get right into kind of
your situation so you're gonna be
stepping down as pastor of the goal tree
Oklahoma UCC Church and the issue you
have a problem with is same-sex marriage
so outline what is the church's position
and what is your position that is so
different that it's causing you to
resign well actually the local level
they agree with me but the problem is
that they don't want to leave the
denomination they're great people but so
I think let me reframe it because I want
to walk people through it churches in
the UCC recognized and consolidation
that's what you disagree with right I
just want to be totally
so our audience who were taps about
absolutely I I first became a part of
the UCC back in 2008 and was driving
down to Oklahoma City I was actually a
part of a church that's mostly gay and
lesbian for a while and then once I
graduated seminary I had to find a
preaching position but the more I the
more I personal study I did on my own
the more I realized that what I was what
I had been taught in seminary and what I
learned through the denomination wasn't
accurate so explain that so what what is
your view of same-sex marriage I I
define marriage between a man or woman
that comes from the Bible what I've
discovered over dealing with people in
the denomination is that the more that
they value experience over scripture the
more liberal they are and the more that
they value the Bible over experience
than the more conservative they tend to
be now as someone who has studied this
and is a student of knowledge so to
speak
wouldn't it tell you that if people base
their lives and their points of views
more on their experience and their
thinking than on what a book purportedly
written by God tells them maybe that's
more what we should be listening to
maybe experience and logic tell us more
about how we should treat gay and
lesbian couples than a book clearly
written by humans but supposedly written
by God tells us maybe maybe we could
learn from that well let me make one
thing clear and this is probably where
some conservatives would disagree with
me on is that I don't think of this as
being in salvation I think there are
people who are gay and lesbian who are
genuinely saved that's nice I will see
who I will see on the other side okay
and and the thing about like my
experience with cathedral of hope is
that these people are genuinely wanting
to do the right thing
they do reach out to people at the gay
pride event and there are thousands of
people there and it was really
disheartening you know it's like the
Sunday night service after that weekend
would take place and you might have
three or four new people show up when
you literally handed out thousands of
Flyers and buttons and you had people
participate in this parade either on
Friday or Saturday and then very few
people showed up so yeah that can be
tough but the salvation of the people
yeah and I'm not either but but
salvation aside just for a second it
sounds like your opposition to gay
marriage lesbian marriage is primarily
Bible based in other words you didn't
mention one anti-gay argument which is
it's not natural you didn't mention the
it doesn't lead to reproduction you
didn't mention well it's a legal
redefinition and I don't like that
correct me if I'm wrong but your
opposition is mostly Bible based is that
right well I would say that and here's
the thing that really kind of threw a
red flag up for me is that a lot of the
people I spoke with that are gay and
lesbian whenever I would mention things
like bigamy polygamy and other things
they never really wanted to draw the
line there they never really want to say
well that stuff is bad what I'm hearing
now is the idea of marriage equality for
everybody will have to have some kind of
limits because if you don't then then
then what are you defining marriage well
that's interesting because and again you
and I are talking we're not having a
legal discussion obviously religious
texts have no bearing at all on on legal
structure in this country whether you
agree with that or not with me we're
leaving that out for this conversation
but let's address it from the point of
view of the Bible the Bible talks about
men with multiple wives men with
multiple wives and concubines etc etc so
is it not arbitrary to say that because
of the Bible you are against gay
marriage for example although the Bible
talks about multiple wives concubines
etc talks about stoning you're you
that your wife if she's not a virgin on
her on the wedding day etc isn't it all
just kind of cherry-picking well the
thing about that is I'm glad you brought
it up is that you really can't find one
example of a healthy relationship where
where somebody did have multiple wives I
think the Bible mentions in 1st
Corinthians that we have the old test as
an example for us and really if you
think about it could you really have two
three four wives and love each one of
them equally and the same I don't think
you can so let's use that I like that I
like that you're applying that question
which is let's just think about this
logically and say can you really be
married to four people and love them
equally and have that type of
relationship and you're thinking the
answer is no what is it about a
relationship between one man and one
woman
I'm sorry between two men or between two
women where you couldn't have the same
type of love that you have in a
male/female relationship applying just
the kind of casual logic test that you
apply just a second ago well to add some
further to the design of marriage I
think the thing that makes marriage so
great is that you're you're married to
somebody who thinks differently you buy
during the last 13 plus years my wife
has challenged me he stretched me
really your wife has read to you I would
say well just when I was when I first
got married I was very selfish and very
self-centered and I did not even realize
how much so during the time we've been
married I've learned how to care for
others in a way that you know James what
you're saying what you're saying James
if I may you're going down an incredibly
misogynistic path which is suggesting
that only women can teach men how to
care for others you're also using very
anecdotal evidence which as a student to
who someone who is an educated person
I'm sure you know that anecdotal
evidence is not really what we should
talk about to discuss broad policy or or
ideas it seems incredibly offensive to
so many men too
say that women are what is needed to
learn to care about others well I think
it goes two ways I think there are
things that she's learned about life for
me as well the the I'm contrasting that
to two men or two women because in least
in my opinion it's a mirror image you're
you're with somebody who does think like
you do and isn't really going to
challenge you on certain things I just
think that this is a very silly argument
though James because the idea that you
think the same as anyone else who is the
same gender as you and therefore you
wouldn't learn from from marriage I've
honestly it's an interest it's I'm
interested in this idea because I've
never heard it before but it's not a
very strong argument is it well we'll
have to agree to disagree on that one
okay I know me personally my life is
very fulfilling good and now if you were
attracted to men if you were born just
being attracted to men would you not be
fulfilled if you were able to marry the
man that you loved hypothetically right
would you would you not find fulfilment
in that hmm that's a interesting
question I probably honestly I don't
know I've - I'm - it's so hard for you
to imagine not being straight because
you were born straight correct
yeah I'm not gonna completely dismiss
the science that I think you're
referring to but I think there needs to
be more done as far as whether or not
you can be born okay I think there needs
to be more scientific research I'm also
Michael my question is what is I guess a
say did you ever decide James you when
you were I don't know seven to say okay
well right now I'm completely neutral
between being attracted to men or women
I think I'm going to choose to be
attracted to women you never had that
revelation did you well most of my time
up until the age of ten I was either
playing basketball football or kickball
so that's fair perfectly fair so what
ten is when is that when you made the
decision you could have gone either way
you could have been into guys you could
have been into
rules and you said well I'm ten I played
enough kickball
now I'm gonna choose to be into women is
that how it went for you or did you at
some point just realize you're attracted
to women that's an interesting question
it was the actual first girl I was
attracted to probably 6th grade I knew a
girl named Shannon who had failed her
grade and so she was a little bit more
jealous a physically mature than some
and so you were attracted you were
attracted to your classmates breasts and
that was 8 that was a physical reaction
you had you never said I'm going to
decide today to like my classmates
breasts that just happened okay I think
I see that you're kind of putting up
some obstacles but I think the audience
kind of gets where I'm going with this
we are at a time James I wish you the
best of luck I'm sorry that your
opposition to marriage equality is
leaving you to leave your position I
hope you find a new position and I do
thank you for joining us thank you so
much have a great day